le dénouement d'une journée de violences
dans les rues d'istanbul en turquie
cette militante d'extrême gauche qu'on
voit ici alors qu'elle est cernée par la
police venait d'attaquer le consulat
américain
elle a été blessée et puis arrêtez ce
n'est qu'une des quatre attaques qui ont
secoué la turquie aujourd'hui la double
offensive que mène le pays contre l'état
islamique et les séparatistes kurdes
semble plus que jamais avoir attisé les
tensions pour en parler j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir marie-eve bédard notre
correspondante au moyen-orient qui est
de passage à montréal bon sens marié
levant soit scellé alors d'abord ses
militants d'extrême gauche qui sont ils
que veulent t'ils en turquie alors le
parti front révolutionnaire de
libération du peuple de la turquie c'est
un groupe qui est considéré comme une
organisation terroriste par le
gouvernement turc est par le
gouvernement américain
par exemple c'est un groupe d'extrême
gauche d'inspiration marxiste qui se dit
surtout anti américain anti impérialiste
c'est pas la première fois dont on parle
de en turquie il avait entre autre
revendiqué aussi en attente en 2013
un attentat suicide contre l'ambassade
des états unis dans la capitale ankara
aujourd'hui ils ont revendiqué cet
attentat en déclarant que leur lutte
allait se poursuivre jusqu'à ce que
le moindre recoin de la turquie soit
libérée des impérialistes et de leurs
collaborateurs et que la turquie soit
libre des bases militaires américaines
ce qu'il faut dire c'est l'insee qui
hier le gouvernement américain a annoncé
que six de ses avions de chasse étaient
en route vers la turquie pour pouvoir
utiliser une base dans le sud du pays
pour mener leurs opérations de
bombardement contre le groupe hermitage
islamique du côté de la série donc c'est
ce qui expliquerait en partie ces
attentats d'aujourd'hui ils sont pas les
seuls d'ailleurs il ya eu d'autres
attentats dont deux ont été revendiqués
ou ont été attribués à des kurdes plus
tôt qu'est ce qui explique cette flambée
de violence tout à coup en turquie qui
avait été relativement épargné quand
même depuis par rapport aux pays voisins
de la syrie
mais on sent la turquie de plus en plus
prise dans cet engrenage la violence
depuis les attentats terroristes de
juillet dernier dans la ville de sour
outch c'est près de la frontière
syrienne dans le cas des kurdes
évidemment ils réagissent ou gestes
posés par le gouvernement de la turquie
qui en emboîtant le pas à la coalition
finalement après des demandes répétées
des américains aux opérations aériennes
de bombardement ils ont frappé le groupe
hermitage smic mais aussi les positions
du pkk un parti kurde qui lui est du
côté du nord de l'irak mais qui a des
affiliations avec le pkk turc qui lui
considéré aussi comme une organisation
terroriste y avait une trêve depuis un
peu plus d'un an entre le gouvernement
turc qui tentait de négocier un retour
peut être à la vie politique normale
pour le pkk mais cette très jolie en
éclats maintenant depuis l'implication
de la turquie de façon militaire parce
que plusieurs reproches du côté des
cures de se servir de la lutte contre le
groupe armé islamique comme couverture
pour s'en prendre aux kurdes qui leur
font beaucoup plus peur d'une certaine
façon pour la stabilité de la turquie la
dernière chose que le gouvernement de la
turquie veut sur son territoire c'est
d'abord un voisin kurde indépendant un
pays indépendant à ses frontières et
même sur son territoire est-ce que sa
place pas la coalition internationale
justement qui lutte contre l'état
islamique contre le groupe etat
islamique dans une position délicate
parce que les kurdes sont assez
efficaces sur le terrain dans cette
lutte là ben voilà c'est le groupe qu'il
est probablement jusqu'ici le plus actif
au sol la coalition bombarde depuis près
d'un an en appui à plusieurs forces mais
les kurdes eux ont repris du territoire
et les américains l'ont fait même si
aussi les considère comme un groupe
terroriste
les ont appuyés avec leur bombardement
on pense à covan et par exemple où ils
ont été très importants pour chasser le
i de ces villes en mariée vous retournez
à beyrouth demain donc on vous
retrouvera pour les prochains jours dans
votre couverture merci beaucoup avec les
yeux